I'm just gonna dive right in guys.
Okay.
So, we're really looking to freshen up our identity,...
...make our brand really stand alone.
We want this to look totally premium...
...with a serious edge.
Serious edge, guys.
Yeah.
So, something with a different feel.
Exactly.
I don't know.
Maybe some quirky little characters.
Awesome.
Quirky characters.
Right.
Okay, so you're looking for something really unique.
No, no.
Not just unique, Ted, something truly brilliant on a grand scale.
Right.
You mean something big?
No Ted, bigger than big.
I'm thinking of something epic!
But what about making something tiny?
Really tiny?
No, really, really tiny...
...and precious.
That sounds totally doable.
I think it needs to be a lot more edgy, more abstract.
Maybe just like in black and white.
Exactly!
But with a bit of color.
Actually scratch that.
Ideally, we really want it to look sweet, I mean, cute but not really.
I totally visualize it now.
Nothing weird though, Ted, okay?